es war wirklich arbeiten an einem Ort wo
andere Leute Urlaub machen und 40.000
weitere machen das gleiche wie ich
mitten im wüstenferien Paradies in Sharm
el-Sheikh findet nämlich die wichtigste
Klimakonferenz des Jahres statt für
Interesse sind gigantisch
unterschiedlich
wird die Klimakrise hier wirklich
bekämpft oder gibt's nur heiße Luft
ich bin in Ägypten einem Staat ohne
Meinungsfreiheit unterwegs als
klimajournalist bin ich hergeflogen alle
TeilnehmerInnen müssen hier im
Clubhotels übernachten mit
animations-tourismus und Klimakonferenz
ist gigantisch Ägypten
Handlungen sind unglaublich zäh die
machen mich sehr sorgen
eine Klimakonferenz im Ferienparadies
die einen Klimaschaden mit sich bringt
lohnt sich das auf dem Weg nach Ägypten
von Zürich nach Sharm el-Sheikh mit dem
Flieger und einem zwischenstoppe ich
reise mit gemischten Gefühlen meine
Rechte als Journalist werden in Ägypten
eingeschränkt sein und das ist nur ein
Punkt der mir Sorgen bereitet
zu einer Klimakonferenz zu fliegendes
macht nicht wirklich ein gutes Gewissen
zumal ich auch noch in Istanbul
zwischenland muss und das ist wirklich
nicht grün auf der anderen Seite hoffe
ich dass es sich lohnt auf eine Kontrast
natürlich riesig ist zwischen dem
wüstenferienort mit klimatisierten
Räumen und Poolanlagen und einem ernsten
Thema wo es darum geht dass wir ein
Klimawandel bekämpfen müssen mit meiner
Reise allein bekämpfe ich ihn jedenfalls
nicht ich hoffe die nächsten Tage lohnen
sich
bei mir kommt trotz dieser Kulisse keine
Ferienstimmung auf
[Musik]
ich habe keine Zeit hier am Strand zu
liegen denn ich treffe gleich den Chef
verhändler der Schweizer Delegation
guten Morgen du musst ganz schnell
loslegen
Franz Perry fährt die 4 km bis zur
Konferenz jeden Morgen mit dem Fahrrad
ich kriege von der Delegation ebenfalls
eins und bin froh als Velofahrer ein
kleines klimazeichen setzen zu können
achtung jetzt kommt Gegenverkehr
der Jurist gibt Gas und nicht nur auf
dem Fahrrad sondern auch in den
Klimaverhandlungen
er vertritt die Schweiz und Schweizer
Interessen wenn es um Maßnahmen gegen
die Erderwärmung geht seit 12 Jahren ist
der dabei
Delegation
die wichtigsten Fragen die da anstehen
von Verhandlungen und die Strategien für
den Tag
so
da darf ich nicht dabei sein
bei den Tempo drauf
ich bin total am Ende der Tag hat gerade
erst angefangen
voll verschwitzt von daher kein weiteres
T-Shirt dabei
Franz rennt von Verhandlung zu
Verhandlung die Mission der Schweizer
lautet die Einhaltung des Pariser
Abkommens
die Erde soll sich nicht mehr als um 1,5
Grad erwärmen doch das wird schwierig
denn das Gastgeberland Ägypten hat kurz
vor der Konferenz den Fokus auf
Entschädigungen für klimabedingte
Schäden und Verluste gelegt
ein
rückblickend
[Musik]
ein sehr emotionales Thema für die armen
Länder dabei geht es auch um viel Geld
aber es lenkt ab davon verbindliche
Maßnahmen gegen den Klimawandel zu
unterzeichnen das ist ein Problem dieser
Konferenz
während Franz hinter verschlossener
Türer verhandelt sehe ich mich auf der
klimamesse um und merke schnell es geht
hier ums Sehen und Gesehen werden ums
Hören und gehört werden
die vielen Menschen das ganze Material
für ihre Stände und Präsentation das
musste alles von überall hierher
geflogen werden denn wir sind in einer
Ferienstadt die per Flugzeug erreichbar
ist am Rand der Wüste
das sind en viele Leute gerade und
ja die reden alle miteinander deiner
wird irgendwo noch ein Panel gemacht man
hört im Hintergrund irgendwelche
Lautsprecher da gibt es bei den
Italienern einen Kaffee wir machen
gerade Pause was das Panel angeht aber
hier ein paar Meter weiter wird schon
der nächste Film ablaufen und so weiter
also was man hier sieht ist das einfach
tausende Leute da sind die Hallen sind
mit Klimaanlagen stark runtergekühlt
draußen sind es fast 30 Grad da meldet
sich bei mir wieder das schlechte
Gewissen lohnt sich das so groß und über
40.000 Menschen müssen die alle hier
sein ich gehe zum Mediencenter dort
arbeitet mein Kollege vom Radio schon
eine Woche lang
wir sind bei dir ehrlich gesagt ich bin
hierher geflogen und dann sind wir hier
in so klimatisierten Gebäuden ich wach
heute morgen auf guck so das Meer
ansehen eine Poolanlage und alles und
denke du bist im Urlaub und dabei ist es
eine Klimakonferenz ist irgendwie
komisch
es ist zwiespältig die ganze Sache
hattest du überlegt nicht zu fahren aber
fliegen
überhaupt zurück ähm genau
Franz Pere kommt aus der Verhandlung
Zeit für die pflegepersönlicher Kontakte
Handshakes Schulterklopfen
für Franz ein Grund warum sich lohnt an
die Konferenz zu fliegen das ist sehr
wichtig dass man auch gegenseitig Mensch
ich Vertrauen hat zueinander tun sind
diese Vertrauen richtig da kann man auch
mal wenn sie zusammen rausgehen und
zusammen eine Lösung suchen die
vielleicht ein bisschen an an der
ursprünglich Position kratzt das ist am
Schluss auch wichtig ist machen kann
eine Verhandlung jagt die nächste andere
haben schon bekommen
und ich als Journalist muss immer
draußen bleiben
jetzt weiß ich nicht ob du da reinkommst
nein natürlich nicht
jeden Abend ruft Franz die schweizer
Journalisten zu sich und fast für uns
den Tag zusammen ich spüre eine gewisse
Ernüchterung was die Ergebnisse der
Verhandlung angeht und Franz bestätigt
mir mein schlechtes Bauchgefühl
ich mache mich sehr sorgen
schlecht
sind
unterstützungsleiste für die erste
Länder bewegt
funktioniert
nicht gut sind die Position so weit
auseinander mit dem Fahrrad geht zurück
ins Hotel und es fühlt sich an wie in
einer Parallelwelt klassischer Club
Urlaub
Animationsprogramm am Abend sind nur
wenige Touristen da denn die meisten
Gäste sind Konferenzteilnehmer so wie
ich
und das hier kann ich heute abend echt
nicht gebrauchen
[Musik]
neuer Tag es kann nur besser werden
immerhin bin ich mit meinem Velo ganz
klimaneutral unterwegs
eine
Fahrt auf der Autobahn wir sind
insgesamt 8 Spuren für Autos und eine
für Fahrräder nur die Fahrradspur wird
eigentlich nicht benutzt außer von
Schweizern Holländern und ein paar
dehnen habe ich gehört und ja wer weiß
ob es nach der Konferenz überhaupt noch
eine Fahrradspur hier braucht weil alle
sind hier mit dem Auto oder dem Bus
unterwegs
bewaffnete Männer mit Anzügen stehen
alle paar Meter am Straßenrand und
mitten in der Wüste ein klares Zeichen
von Kontrolle
außerhalb der Klimakonferenz lässt die
Ägypten keine Proteste oder
Demonstration zu und wenn Proteste
stattfinden dann wirken sie fast
lächerlich
ein paar Veganer rufen hier zum
fleischport auf
ich höre von einer jungen Ärztin aus
Zürich die mit ihren Aktionen und
Protesten für Aufsehen sorgt Bea
albermann klimaaktivistisch ich bin
gerade da ich kann sie erreichen und
verabrede mich sofort mit ihr auf dem
Gelände der Klimakonferenz
die 25-Jährige ist hierher geflogen weil
sie nicht tatenlos zuschauen will wenn
wichtige Entscheidungen der Klimakrise
getroffen werden
da auf der Straße sie sind das ist doch
vom un-glenz viel es gibt ja kein
Straßen protestungen
so die wichtigste ist sie dass ich auf
ein anderer Arzt geworden
also Bundespräsident und ich bin
ziemlich
was wenn sie eigentlich machen zum
Gesundheitsfonds schützen
aber jetzt bin ich realistisch war
Bundespräsident was heißt denn
realistisch sie in der Zeit wo mir schon
wie 1,2
Millionen für Leute das Leben verlieren
immer mit Todesfall hat währenddessen
realistisch sind Auge vor dem
gesundheitsnobel Verschlüsse oder sagen
Ernst wir entwickelt Maßnahme mir
reagieren so dass mir Bevölkerung
wir treffen Marie Claire Graf die beiden
kennen sich gut Marie Claire ist seit
Jahren auf Klimakonferenzen und hat für
die Schweiz schon mitverhandelt
da kommt plötzlich John Kerry vorbei der
Klima beauftragt der Vereinigten Staaten
von Amerika die USA sind der zweitgrößte
CO2 Verursacher der Welt
Bea geht einfach auf ihn zu und will ihm
die Dringlichkeit der Klimakrise aus
medizinischer Sicht mitteilen
auch hier Ernüchterung
Investitionen machen sie sind weiterhin
Subvention am schützen
wir machen das ne ganze
um 17 Uhr wird es dunkel und ein
weiterer kleiner Protest findet auf dem
Gelände statt das Fossil des Tages
[Musik]
international
one thous 1935
Marie Claire kritisiert die ägyptische
Präsidentschaft auch in der Vorbereitung
der Klimakonferenz es seien falsche
Prioritäten gesetzt worden sodass die
Konferenz gar nicht zu den gewünschten
Ergebnissen führen können
momentan
in der Verhandlungen
fehlt vor der Präsidentschaft wo wo
Kaiser Mann aufgebaut hat Kai Lieder
kommt
falscher Gastgeber unter den Gaststätten
vor der letzten Konferenz sind Glasgow
letztes Jahr hat die Regierung bereits
Monate im Voraus mit den Vorbereitungen
der Verhandlungen begonnen dadurch
konnten sie in den zwei Wochen der
Konferenz mehr erreichen weil sie
einfach schon weiter waren also ist der
Ort ein Ferienparadies wurde das eine
was kritisch zu bedenken ist aber auch
wie Ägypten die Länder in diese
Konferenz geleitet hat könnte das der
Knackpunkt sein warum sich diese
Konferenz hier vielleicht nicht lohnen
wird
aber es gibt auch eine andere Seite von
Sharm el Sheikh
kurz nach 6 Uhr morgen und wir gehen
gleich Schnorcheln ja deswegen extra so
früh weil da die Farben im Wasser am
besten sein sollte dass man die Fische
und Korallen uns am besten sehen kann
weil das hier ist wohl ein Paradies
zwischen euchler so schön ist es kaum
noch auch irgendwo auf der Welt zum
Schnorcheln
mit meinen Kollegen vom Radio geht's zum
Wasser alles hier im Ferienparadies ist
künstlich aufgebaut das einzig echte ist
wohl die Vielfalt im Meer
tatsächlich solch ein Taucherparadies
gibt es kaum noch auf der Welt wie hier
[Musik]
denn weltweit sind Korallenriffe stark
bedroht und sterben ab
immerhin dadurch wird einem hier in
Ägypten klar was wir durch die
Klimakrise verlieren
[Musik]
wirklich kannte Schnorcheln bis zu
diesem Tag noch nicht ist der Hammer
deshalb wahnsinn was man da unten sieht
alles bunt
das war geil krass
super super schön
vom Strand geht es wieder zur
Klimakonferenz und es wird sehr
emotional die klimaaktivistin BEA kann
mit Bundesrätin Simonetta Sommaruga
sprechen und ich darf dabei sein
ich glaube
weil die Bundesräte mich sehr berühmt da
froh dass mir als Jugend da vor Ort als
ermäßig sind
[Musik]
meinst es hat was gebracht bei ihr etwas
zu sagen überhaupt
na was mir eigentlich dass mir da sind
nicht wenn wir das cool finden wenn wir
Spaß sind wie cool ich hoffe
viel mehr leben
zum anstatt zum traurig sie zum hässlich
sind
mit was für einem Gefühl sind sie gerade
auf der Konferenz hier wie es ihr Gefühl
von der Konferenz
realistische Seite
es ist aber vielleicht ein bisschen zu
groß angesetzt das ganze und vielleicht
das Setting auch nicht perfekt
ausgewählt ja also ich danke
schon aus sinnvoll und auch machbar
erwartet dass man jetzt
kontrolliert kommt
Interesse sind gigantisch
unterschiedlich
das ist schwierig
vielen Dank danke für die Zeit das war
eine gute diplomatische Antwort ich kann
ja auch nicht sagen das ist ja alles
Mist und es lohnt sich nicht herzukommen
also auf der anderen Seite habe ich
immer mehr das Gefühl dass bei dieser
Konferenz wirklich nicht
jetzt greifbares bei rauskommt leider
es ist der letzte Konferenztag und die
Verhandlungen stecken fest intensiv
diskutieren Simonetta Sommaruga und
Franz peré ich darf die beiden nicht
mehr ablenken ein Ergebnis wird an
diesem Tag noch nicht feststehen das
sagt mir der Pressesprecher schade
ich bleibe nicht länger und fliege
zurück
einen schalen Beigeschmack nehme ich aus
Ägypten mit weil hier keinen Drive keine
Klima Action erfahren habe sondern
scheinbar mehr Probleme als Lösungen
Thema waren erst einen Tag später wird
ein gemeinsames Statement und Ergebnis
der Länder veröffentlicht immerhin es
gibt eins doch bringt es uns auch weiter
das Ergebnis der Klimakonferenz steht
fest für klimabedingte Schäden der
armenländer soll jetzt ein Fonds
eingerichtet werden und das ist ein
Erfolg für all diejenigen die jetzt
schon am meisten unter dem Klimawandel
leiden um das 1,5 Grad Ziel aber
weiterhin zu erhalten da sind wir keinen
Deut weitergekommen und da würde ich
persönlich sagen dass ich ein
Ferienparadies als Austragungsort einer
Klimakonferenz und Ägypten als Gastgeber
im Kampf gegen den Klimawandel nicht
gelohnt haben also dafür spricht doch so
einiges doch was muss ich ändern damit
es endlich schneller geht und etwas
passiert lohnen sich solche
Klimakonferenzen überhaupt noch ich bin
gespannt auf deine Kommentare schreibt
sie unten rein und wenn du magst
abonniere den Kanal